la gráfica de abajo contiene el
rectángulo
bcp a b c p
dibuja la imagen de bsp bajo una
potencia cuyo centro es p y cuya razón
de noticias uno con dos tercios cuáles
son las medidas del lado ave y de su
imagen bueno si voy a realizar una
noticia con centro en p entonces todos
los puntos después de realizar la
noticia se tienen que alejar por el
factor de potencia es decir en este caso
tienen que estar uno con dos tercios
veces más lejos por ejemplo el punto p
está una distancia cero del punto p por
lo tanto su imagen tiene que estar a una
distancia cero del punto p por lo tanto
el punto p se queda en dónde está el
punto c está
tiene la misma coordenada x desde -7
pero el punto p tiene coordenada 73 y el
punto c coordenadas menos 3 por lo tanto
esta distancia es de 6 unidades 6 por 1
con dos tercios pues seis por dos
tercios es 4 así que uno con dos tercios
por seis sería 10 el punto se tiene que
terminar diez unidades de distancia de
aquí hasta seis así que se tiene que
alejar otras cuatro unidades
una dos tres cuatro así que termina aquí
en -7 el punto y tiene la misma
coordenadas del punto p pero su
coordenada x es diferente el punto p
tiene coordenada de x menos 7 el punto a
tiene coordenada x menos 4 por lo tanto
esta instancia es de 3
y esa instancia es de 33 por 1 con dos
tercios pues tres por dos tercios es dos
así que tres por uno con dos tercios
serían cinco
así que aquí estamos a 3 me tengo que
alejar otras dos unidades 1 2 y terminó
y ahora sólo completó el rectángulo y
noten que este punto que sería la imagen
del punto b el punto b estaba a tres
unidades en la dirección xy ahora está a
cinco unidades en la dirección x y
estaba a seis unidades en la dirección
ya y ahora está a diez unidades en la
dirección y contestemos la pregunta ave
mide cuántas unidades pues ave ya lo
dijimos mide seis unidades seis unidades
y su imagen mide cuánto pues esta
instancia es de tres a menos siete
es de 10 unidades
comprobemos la respuesta ya estamos en
lo correcto